TAODICISIT IS EDITEDOMPILATION
TO HEA AND L [
>>ND CALL INTHP AN OF -->> A A
TH A [ BLEEP ].  THERE SHOULD B
>> AND ESPECIALLY TH [
>> AND TT IS
] WEEEPD COUL SAY AND
ABLE.
SO I
AND WHAT I?
WHAEY
HAVE TO  AFTER
TH OANTI-VACCINE, AN
INDI THE
THAT HE
RE PROBLEMATIC THA AROUNIN INK D
DEER BUT HERE  RANT OF THEAPOLOG
I AM MA T
HAD TOPUBLICLY. TH VIDEO O, S A
CONVER THECAHETOD IT IHORRIBLE R
ER ALLOWSAY THAT WORD,N PODCAS Y
BUT A LONG IOULDG THAT, LIKE IF
VE ICIE I AM NOTERERT
YESHE HAS, JIM.
COMPILATION WHICHAS ADMITTED T A
THAT IO OF A J,  SEEMS
UNTENABLE  H KIND OFVIDEO SURFA
COION SUD  S JOB, BUTE  PATRI
PUO , D  ROG
HE DESCRIB TT OF
APES, AND IT IS AWFUL,UT SHOW
ITAN A, TAKE
THIS ONE, AND THE GUY , E,
THS
OUT AND
WITHEG"PLANET  WD  THED
INTO AFRICA AND INTO THEPLE.
ROGAN,SED  ITHASELAT TO OUT
THAT?
ON PODCAST
TH HEAM
S WHAT H T
, NOR WOULI EV E AREEP ]ing SOUD
RW TO  "PLANET OF
THNO
I WA
PEOPLTHERE.
OTT Y.
T
>> GAHEAD.
JIM,NDO SE THIS,
WORK, IL
CONTENT, AND THEY ARYING HIM
HUNDREDS
G E EPISODES ORDHAVE SAID THAT
DOE EPISODES
HA SHE CLEANO ERASE PASTD WILLHE
SE WE  HEARD  JOE ROGAN CONTINUN
, BUT IT DT VE AND SOME
OF TOM WHO PUTHE
PLATFORMEY HAV THERE,  BRIAN?ART
>> COMPANIES L
IN BUSINES DISTETHEMSELVESPLATF
E IN
THAT B W THBUT E A CHOICEMIGHT A
SOLLTHATUT THAT ISHA IS TOCOY D
WHY MIGHITE OB. SOFANIMED IT ISB
>> IT GH DIFFERENT,
BECAUSE BENTE BUSINESS AND BEFO,
THSTU  THIS LLN
JIM, THEREY EXAMPLEST
WHERE PEOPLE HAVE LOST THEIR
YBANTHONS THAT ROGAN HAS N, BEC
D
COSAVILEHAT IS IN THIS
COMPILATION.
>> RS ITNE
IT HPE OVENOS